le président d'agglomération et même
président d'un département dans le cas
du ministre des Armées y aura-t-il donc
des ministres privilégiés de fortes
têtes capricieux un problème d'autorité
de votre part Madame le Ministre
comptez-vous enfin faire appliquer cette
règle que le mini le chef de l'État
lui-même avait rappelé en 2017 allez
vous faire démissionner de leur mandats
locaux les ministres concernés
[Applaudissements]
Carole Darmanin
les bras que les bras connus étant les
meilleurs garde de chasse dans la
prémisse ma bonne répondent à votre
question monsieur le sénateur Paco
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que au nom
du gouvernement et bien sûr de la
première ministre les règles seront
respectées plusieurs ministres ont déjà
démissionné de leur fonction exécutives
et ils ont quelques semaines à demander
la première ministre pour pouvoir
convoquer leurs assemblées délibérantes
afin de démissionner toutes et tous de
leur exécutif tout en restant évidemment
conseiller municipal conseil
départemental au conseil régional
j'espère que vous ne reprochez pas mon
gouvernement que vous évoquez parfois un
peu distant du terrain d'être par
ailleurs élu faudra pas non plus que ce
soit une retard vérité ici
mensonge au-delà monsieur le sénateur
Paco une fois que j'ai rappelé cette
règle qui je crois peut vous plaire j'ai
compris qu'il y avait aussi une question
de départementale dans votre question et
que sans doute la ministre de votre
département à laquelle vous partagiez
j'imagine un moment de sympathie lors de
l'assemblée des mères de samedi dernier
dans le l'Oise purée si vous rappelez
que la règle évoquée bien sûr est
informelle mais a toujours connu des
exception le ministre Jean-Yves Le Drian
a été ministre de la Défense tout en
étant président de la Région Bretagne il
me semble d'ailleurs que le président
Nicolas Sarkozy a été très longuement
ministre de l'intérieur tout en étant
maire de Neuilly président du conseil
départemental des Hauts-de-Seine
quelques témoins sont monsieur Barouin a
longtemps été maire de Troyes tout en
étant ministre monsieur Pacaud monsieur
Pacaud monsieur paco est voté évoqué une
règle que les moins de 25 ans pouvaient
pas connaître mais comme nous avons je
crois le même compagnon de neige et il a
sans doute oublié un certain nombre de
dispositions qui lui déplaisait
monsieur Paco
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre je félicite
le bon élève l'ancien maire de Tourcoing
d'avoir répondu et nous avons tous pris
note que les ministres rebelles
démissionnerait bientôt reste un bar
nous ne voulons pas de parole nous
voulons des actes c'est ce que mérite
nos citoyens et nos territoires et la
question d'autorité est d'exemplarité
sont la clé du problème comment
voulez-vous Madame le Ministre être obéi
entre guillemets des français quand un
ministre effrontément Bafou la règle et
quel comble de voir l'armée ou le sens
de la hiérarchie et de la discipline
sont les valeurs cardinales dirigées par
un ministre rebelle commune voilà
l'exemplarité de se proclame pas elle se
pratique
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]